in an iaea quarterly report leaked last
week the nuclear Watchdog said its
inspectors had found particles of
uranium in Iran enriched to near weapons
grade returning from a visit to Tehran
the organization's Chief said that did
not mean Iran was actually producing
such material there has not been
production or accumulation of uranium at
that level which is a very high level of
course 60 is already very high but as I
said we have we Ways and Means to
inspect it weapons grade uranium is
enriched to 90 percent Iran said the
finding of 83.7 percent at one of its
sites was an unintended fluctuation
in their report they mentioned particles
of 84 84 there is not enrichment
activity at that level there was no
enriched uranium above 60 percent this
ambiguity has been somehow resolved
it all comes at a sensitive time with
attempts to restore the joint
comprehensive plan of action the nuclear
deals signed with Tehran in 2015. then
president Trump withdrew unilaterally
from the jcpoa in 2018 and imposed
multiple sanctions on Iran
we want to continue our relations with
the iaea for the agency to be able to
perform its duties regarding Iran's
nuclear program within the framework of
the comprehensive safeguards agreement
we stress the need to avoid issues that
would hit our relations with the iaea
Iranian president Ibrahim raisi echoed
those sentiments in his meeting with the
iaea head but warned Iran's rights had
to be respected
last week the CIA director William Burns
expressed concern about Iran's nuclear
program we don't see evidence that they
made a decision to resume their
weaponization program but the other
dimensions of this challenge I think are
growing at a worrisome Pace too Tehran
has always maintained its nuclear
program it's for peaceful purposes
nicktoxig Al Jazeera